je suis d'une enseignante du primaire
est impatient de retrouver ses élèves
mais elle a des craintes que comme tous
les parents c'est certain qu'on a peur
ou à la contamination mais je me dis que
d'un côté il faut faire confiance à la
santé publique
le gouvernement du québec étudie
plusieurs scénarios de retour à l'école
on n'est pas rendu le jeu de ces genres
de questions où l'on y aura des
consignes mais on est jeu est bien clair
là on est pauvre en du lot l'allier pas
question de réouvrir à court terme les
écoles parmi les scénarios envisagés
celui d'un retour partiel des élèves en
me comme l'a déjà d'ailleurs évoqué le
premier ministre déjà certains
directeurs d'école se prépare ça pour
être partielle certain nombre d'élèves
qui rendent la matinée un autre nombre
d'élèves qui lance l'après midi pour
faire des enfants du parcours
pédagogique a fait 2-2 déclassé pour
l'année suivante
mais cette enseignante comme plusieurs
autres appréhendent un retour précipité
c'est nous qui allons devant accueillir
les élèves qui allons devoir le
gouvernement du québec étudie aussi la
possibilité d'un retour complet des
élèves uniquement septembre c'est
certain qu'en septembre
ça me donne plus de temps mais au niveau
des apprentissages c'est une autre chose
ça ça veut dire que ça va faire six mois
qu'on aura pas vu nos élèves du tout
mais ce scénario suscite d'autres
craintes
à québec on redoute que si l'immunité
collective est trop faible
on se retrouve avec une deuxième vague
de cas de coronavirus au moment de la
période de la grippe à l'automne sept
des 10 min et collectif c'est
tout à fait compréhensible mais ça ça
veut pas dire que des adultes qui sont
capables de jouer avec leur santé non
plus ne le défi s'annonce de taille pour
les écoles qui font déjà face à une
pénurie de personnel et qui pourraient
se retrouver sans enseignant et sans
chauffeur d'autobus de plus 60 ans ici
jean philippe robillard et au canada
montréal